what I want to do in this video is show
you a way to represent a vector by its
components and this is sometimes called
engineering notation for vectors but
it's super useful because it allows us
to keep track of the components of the
vector and it makes it a little bit
tangible when we talk about the
individual components so let's break
down this vector right over here I'm
just assuming it's a velocity vector
vector V it's magnitude is 10 meters per
second and it's pointed in a direction
30 degrees above above the horizontal so
we've broken down these vectors in the
past before the vertical component right
over here its magnitude its magnitude
would be so the magnitude of the
vertical component right over here is
going to be 10 sine of 30 degrees is
going to be 10 meters per second times
the sine of 30 degrees sine of 30
degrees this comes from the basic
trigonometry from sohcahtoa and I cover
that in more detail in previous videos
sine of 30 degrees is one-half so this
is going to be five or five meters per
second ten times one half is five five
meters per second so that's the
magnitude of its vertical component and
in the last few videos I kind of in a
less tangible way of specifying the
vertical vector I often use this
notation which isn't as tangible as I
like and that's why I'm gonna make it a
little bit better in this video I said
that that vector itself is five meters
per second five meters per second but
what I told you is that the direction is
implicitly given because this is a
vertical this is a vertical vector and I
told you in previous videos that if it's
positive it means up and if it's
negative it means down so I kind of had
to give you this context here so that
you could appreciate that this is a
vector that just the sine of it is
giving you its direction but I had to
keep telling you this is a vertical
vector so it was a little bit it wasn't
that tangible and so we had the same
issue when we talked about the way the
same issue we talked about the
horizontal vectors so this horizontal
vector right over here the magnitude of
it the magnitude of this horizontal
vector is going to be ten cosine of 30
degrees and once again it comes straight
out of basic trigonometry
and cosine of 30 degrees and so cosine
of 30 degrees is square root of 3 over 2
square root of 3 over 2 multiply it by
10 you get 5 square roots of 3 5 square
roots of 3 meters per second and once
again in previous videos I said look
this is actually I used this notation
some times where I was actually saying
that the vector is 5 square roots of 3
meters per second but in order to ensure
that this wasn't just a magnitude I kept
having to tell you in the horizontal
direction if it's positive it's going to
the right and if it's negative it's
going to the left what I want to do in
this video is give us a convention so
that I don't have to keep doing this for
the direction and it all it makes it all
a little bit more tangible and so what
we do is we introduce the ideas of or
the idea of unit vectors of unit vectors
so by definition we'll introduce the
vector I the vector I sometimes it's
called I hat and I'll draw it like here
so the vector I'll make it a little bit
smaller so the vector I hat so that
right there is a picture of the vector I
hat and we put that little hat on top of
the eye to show that it is a unit vector
and what a unit vector is so I hat goes
in the positive x-direction that's just
how it's defined and we also the unit
vector tells us that it's magnitude is 1
so I the magnitude of the vector I hat
is equal to 1 and its direction is in
the positive x-direction so if we really
wanted to specify this the this the X
this this kind of X component vector in
a better way we really should call it we
really should call it 5 square roots of
3 times this unit vector because it's 5
this green vector over here is going to
be 5 square roots of 3 times this vector
right over here because this vector just
has length 1 so it's 5 square roots of 3
times the unit vector and what I like
about this is now I don't have to tell
you remember this is a horizontal vector
or positive is positive is to the right
negative to the left it's implicit here
because clearly if this is a positive
value it's going to be a it's going to
be a positive multiple of I it's going
to go to the right if it's an
negative value it flips around the
vector and then it goes to the left so
this is actually a better way of
specifying of specifying the x-component
vector or if I broke it down this vector
V into its X component this is a better
way of specifying that vector same thing
for the Y Direction we can define a unit
vector and let me pick a color that I
have not used yet let me find a well
this pink I haven't used we can define a
unit vector that goes straight up in the
Y direction called unit vector J and
once again the magnitude of unit vector
J is equal to one this little hat on top
of it tells us or sometimes it's called
a character a carrot character that
tells us that it is a vector but it is a
unit vector it has a magnitude of one
and by definition the vector J goes in
is is has a magnitude of 1 in the
positive y direction so this the Y
component of this vector instead of
saying it's 5 meters per second in the
upward direction or instead of saying
that it's implicitly upwards because
it's a vertical vector or it's a
vertical component and it's positive we
can now be a little bit more a little
bit more specific about it we could say
that it is equal to it is equal to 5
times J 5 times J because you see this
magenta vector it's going the exact same
direction as J the exact same direction
is J it's just 5 times longer I don't
know if it's exactly 5 times I'm trying
to estimate it right now it's just 5
times longer now what's really cool
about this is besides just being able to
express the components as now multiples
of explicit vectors instead of just
being able to do that which we did do
we're representing the components as
explicit vectors we also know that the
vector V is the sum of its components if
you add if you start with this vector
this this green vector right here and
you add this vertical component right
over here you have head to tails you get
you get the blue vector and so we can
actually use the components to represent
the vector itself we won't we don't
always have to draw it like this
so we can write that vector V is equal
to it's equal to vector we write it this
way it's equal to its x-component vector
plus the y-component vector plus the
y-component vector and we can write that
the x component vector is 5 square roots
of 3 5 square roots of 3 times i 5
square roots of 3 times i and then it's
going to be plus the plus the y
component the vertical component which
is 5 j which is 5 5 times j and so
what's really neat here is now you can
specify any vector in two dimensions by
some combination of eyes and JS or some
scaled up combinations of eyes and js
and if you want to go into three
dimensions if you want to go to three
dimensions and you often will as
especially as the physics class moves on
through the year you can introduce a
vector in you can introduce a vector in
the positive z direction depending on
how you want to do it although z is
normally up-and-down but whatever the
next dimension is you can define a
define a vector K that goes into that
third dimension here I'll do it in a
kind of unconventional way I'll make K
go in that direction although the
standard convention when you do three
dimensions is that K is the up-and-down
dimension but this by itself is already
pretty neat because we can now represent
any vector any vector through its
components and it's also going to make
the math much easier